here's our first example it takes Zara
20 minutes more to cover 20 percent more
distance this means that if Zara travels
at her speed for 20 more minutes she
would have covered 20 percent more than
the original distance we need to find
the time taken by Zara to travel the
original distance now this is not a
straightforward TST problem where we are
given two parameters and asked to find
the third this example can be divided
into two parts first Zara walking at her
speed for some distance and second Zara
continues walking at the same speed for
20 more minutes to cover some more
distance did you hear me well I said
same speed
it means the speed is constant in both
the paths whenever there are two parts
to a problem the easiest way to
understand it is by using the speed
multiplied by time is equal to distance
formula for each case now as we haven't
been given a numerical value for any of
the parameters let's assume this to be a
first case Zara travels at speed s for
time T and covers distance D now let's
talk about the second case the speed at
which Sarah Travels remains constant so
the speed will remain s for the second
case as well
she takes 20 minutes more than the
original time the time taken will be t
plus 20 and she covers 20% more distance
so the distance will be 1 point 2 D so
these are the two cases in the question
we have just simplified the question we
have to find the time taken to travel
the original distance we need to find T
are these two equations enough to give
us T at the first look you would
probably say no as there are three
variables and just do equations but
let's see if we can work it out we know
that the speed S is the same in both
cases
let's try equating s in the first case s
will equal D over T and in the second
case s would equal one point two D over
t plus 20 D cancels out and we get T
plus 20 equal to 1.2 T solving this we
get the value of t as 100 minutes
Zarah takes 100 minutes to travel the
original distance the beauty about TST
problems is that it does not have to be
done in one specific way if you're not
comfortable doing it this way you can
even look at it
diagrammatically let's say this is the
original distance D time taken by Zara
to cover it is T now let this be 20
percent of the distance as it is 20% of
the original distance it will be equal
to 0.2 D 20% of D is 0.2 D and based on
the question we can say that Zara takes
20 minutes to travel this distance this
0.2 D distance now we can look at these
two parts individually let's assume her
speed is s for the orange part we can
say that s times T is equal to D and for
the blue part we can say that s times 20
is equal to 0.2 D if we divide the 2
equations s and D will get cancelled we
will get T over 20 equal to 1 over 0.2
this will also give us the value of T as
100 minutes you can choose whichever
method you're comfortable with and in
the TST problems there are no rules
about following a particular technique
these two ways are easy to understand
but maybe a bit time-consuming to save
time we need to use an intelligent way
to tackle this problem and that's by
using the concept of variation we know
that the speed is constant it means time
and distance are directly proportional
we are talking about 20% more distance
so the overall distance is multiplied by
1.2 as T varies directly with D we will
also have to multiply T with 1.2 this is
the new time zahra takes to travel 20%
more distance and to travel the original
distance
she takes T units of time now understand
this really well the fact that she takes
20 minutes more implies that the
difference between this time and the
original time will be 20 minutes so 1.2
t minus T will equal 20 minutes and this
gives us t as 100 minutes and this was
really fast if you understand variation
you have to use this technique different
books will give you different solutions
but you have to choose what you are most
comfortable with there is no point in
trying to use the fastest technique if
you don't understand it in every problem
you look at in the future sessions we
will understand different ways to tackle
it
you